kill bill qui l'aurai toute manière
champion de tennis rien qu'en regardant
jouer les meilleurs et c'est vrai qu'il
a un don pour recopier tout ce qu'il
voit à mon avis ce type il doit avoir un
magnéto dans la tête et un synthé dans
la gorge
en tous les cas ce qu'il télé style bd
tout en flash en spot en gags en spot
voici michel
oui
bonjour et bonjour ça va ça va oui très
bien alors dis-moi michel louis était
plutôt bien habillés
ben pourquoi je serai à jarry vrai et
beau gosse ouais t'as pas de salopettes
ils veulent pas des mobiles est une
jument rate une europe pas non tu parle
plutôt bien le français
oc suspecte tout ça il doit y avoir un
défaut quelque part bien des faux tu
serais pas l'anti coluche à ça je sais
pas alors là c'est c'est toi qui lis un
nom en tout cas nous ne souhaitait pas
tout l'un vers ce mot non moi je crois
que je j'ai sur ma personnalité fait en
sorte que je pratique un humour qui
forcément agressif est qui et qui plaît
aussi bien aux enfants qu'aux grands
parents etc aux jeunes de ton âge et je
dois dire que c'est vrai que l'on m'a
qualifié de clown clean voilà mais je
trouve cette expression amusante clown
clean je trouve ça très sympa
bon j'ai pas d'agressivité mais
bon c'est ma personnalité je ne cherche
pas à ne pas l'être je suis comme ça
j'ai aucune agressivité pour personnes
en tout ont publié un premier livre
c'était la valise en croco oui oui c'est
parce que c'est plus solide qu'une
valise en carton
j'ai pensé que c'est une des raisons
majeures et là tu viens d'en publier un
autre qui s'appelle le dictionnaire dur
et oui alors la 4me l'histoire il ya
quatre mille histoires
est ce que tu peux nous dire la plus
drôle sur 4000 bas il ya une histoire
qui est amusante c'est que la ja il ya
un belge qui est mort en buvant du lait
l'a récemment parce que la vache s'est
assise il y en a beaucoup comme ça et
les matins au réveil on en lit une page
et on en eut une page et comme coluche
et moi justement une somme très copains
il vient consulter dans le dans mon
dictionnaire quelques histoires on peut
se servir tout le monde peut se servir
bombe un avis aux amateurs tout le monde
peut faire